story is just crazy an illegal immigrant
convicted of sexually assaulting a child
in Brazil was just arrested by ice and
marth's Vineyard the Brazilian sex
offender fled his home country after
being sentenced to 14 years in prison he
then evaded border patrol as he crossed
into the US he was a goway joining us
now as former director of New York ice
removal Tom FY so Tom I mean this guy is
able to cross the border he's a GU of
way um and then we picked him up in
Martha's
Vineyard yeah I mean nobody's really
shocked by this anymore right I mean the
border is wide open um people can come
and go as they please and like I've been
saying for two years now on Fox News um
anybody can come here including
terrorists uh this gentleman it's just
it's absolutely ridiculous that this
border is wide open and nobody wants to
do anything so Tom obviously this was a
gotway but we have people that we have
captured given them a notice to
appear that are on the sex offender list
that are known
terrorists you're absolutely accurate
the agency within ice enforcement
removal operations ER they're the sole
agency responsible for removing people
from the United States since Biden has
taken office all the senior leadership
has pretty much retired or left and gone
to do something else and right now this
Administration is actually downsizing
them they're losing positions so this
this individual was apprehended by a
fugitive operations team out of the
Boston field office which is run by a
very very good director but the fact is
we're losing positions so these fugitive
operation teams aren't even fully
staffed anymore to go locate these
individuals yeah it's a just crazy 3.2
million encounters 600,000 known Goda
aways and you got 170 a little bit over
170 people that are on the terror watch
list uh this brings me to my home state
of Texas governor have has endorsed
Donald Trump uh and people are
concerned uh in the Liberals media
because Donald Trump has said look
they're going to be Mass deportation
tell me how president Trump will get
something like that
done so when I worked for president drum
Trump we were called Nazis we were
accused of separating families and
everybody knows if you're arrested from
a crime and you get sentenced to prison
you're obviously you're separated from
your family so I'm sure the left is
getting ready to dust off those signs
that even if it isn't Trump whoever
comes in next and tries to write this
ship and remove the people that don't
belong here they have no legal status
here you're going to be called a Nazi
again they're going to protest outside
your phone your house you know how dare
you you guys are separating families as
we currently turned a blind eye to
literally millions of people crossing
this border including terrorist groups
like Hamas and people say well how do
you know that Hamas is here because when
I was a director I actually interviewed
some of the Hamas that are here they are
here amongst other terrorist
organizations so you know Governor
Abbott I get it you know he lives on the
border he's in this crisis kneed deep as
as you know being from Texas and
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on how you look at it the American
people are scared y they want a
president that they feel protects them
and they want a president that will help
put food on the table people are
struggling yeah that's why the name
calling Jess isn't going to work this
time the American people are are afraid
for their safety they tried to give Jo a
shot to get something done they said
they wanted compy immigration reform
done uh and he said that he was going to
give us some sort of security now we
have a wide open border and terrorists
in the country as a result Tom thank you
so much for your service to the country
and coming on this
morning thanks for having me and have a
great Thanksgiving you too brother I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis